he who laughs at himself
never runs out of things to laugh at
nature hath given men one tongue but two
ears
that we may hear from others twice as
much as we speak
wealth consists not in having great
possessions
but in having few wants
there is only one way to happiness
and that is to cease worrying about
things
which are beyond our power
or our will
man is not worried by real problems
so much is by his imagined anxieties
about real problems
it's not what happens to you
but how you react to it that matters
if you want to improve
be content
to be thought foolish and stupid
the key is to keep company only with
people who uplift you
whose presence calls forth your best
freedom is the only worthy goal in life
it is one by disregarding things that
lie beyond our control
it is impossible for a man to learn what
he thinks he already knows
circumstances don't make the man
they only reveal him to himself
other people's views and troubles
can be contagious
don't sabotage yourself by unwittingly
adopting negative unproductive attitudes
through your associations with others
you are a little soul
carrying around a corpse
first
learn the meaning of what you say
and then speak
no man is free who is not a master of
himself
attach yourself to what is spiritually
superior
regardless of what other people think or
do
hold your true aspirations no matter
what is going on around you
know first who you are
and then adorn yourself accordingly
if evil be said of thee
and if it be true
correct thyself
if it be a lie
laugh at it
small-minded people blame others
average people blame themselves
the why see all blame as foolishness
don't seek to have events happen as you
wish
but wish them to happen as they do
happen
and all will be well with you
know you not that a good man does
nothing for appearance sake but for the
sake of having done right
who is the rich man
he
who is content
it is our attitude toward events
not events themselves which we can
control
nothing is by its own nature calamitous
even death is terrible only if we fear
it
give me by all means the shorter and
nobler life
instead of one that is longer but of
less account
no great thing is created suddenly
any more than a bunch of grapes or a fig
if you tell me that you desire a fig
i answer that there must be time
let it first blossom
then bear fruit
then ripen
it is unrealistic to expect people to
see you as you see yourself
freedom is secured not by the fulfilling
of men's desires
but by the removal of desire
the more we value things outside our
control
the less control we have
difficulty shows what men are
we must not believe the many who say
that only free people ought to be
educated
but we should rather believe the
philosophers who say that only the
educated are free
is freedom anything other than the right
to live as we wish
nothing else
in banquets remember that you entertain
two guests
body and soul
and whatever you shall have given to the
body
you soon eject
but what you shall have given to the
soul
you keep always
be careful with who you communicate with
people tend to imitate habits
those with whom we interact
we inadvertently adopt their interests
their opinions
their values
and their habits interpret events
the most beautiful of all creations
is a well-educated person
a smart person fights passion
but a fool becomes its slave
anyone who can make you angry
becomes your master
it's not a pity that a person was born
or died
that he lost his money at home
all his property does not belong to him
but it's a pity if a person loses his
true property or his dignity
[Music]
you